[Music]
I'm in a church sitting through the
widest rendition of this little light of
mine because an undocumented family is
living here to avoid deportation it
turns out houses of worship are one of
the few places Immigration and Customs
Enforcement or ice won't raid we're
gathered tonight to support our friends
Malik and Zaida
and Rania today marks the 52nd day of
their residence here in Old Lyme for
fear of the consequences I don't like
this ice is shifting focus from
deporting criminals to removing all
undocumented people even if it breaks up
families which may seem monstrous but
I'm gonna do some mental gymnastics to
prove that it's not do you think you
deserve to be here after only being in
the United States for 18 months 18 years
not 18 month my bad I have MS and she's
an American citizen absolutely okay well
she's on my team
but even though Malik and Zaida are
impossibly charming they are not on my
team
you see Malik and Saida entered the US
legally on a visitor visa but they
overstayed that visa when their
application for a new one was mishandled
by their attorney this branded them
permanently as illegal then under Obama
over 4 million undocumented parents of
US citizens like Malik and Zeta were
given temporary legal status as long as
they regularly checked in with ice
thankfully Trump arrived and anyone
foolish enough to voluntarily check in
with ice became a target of ice so on
their last visit ice ordered them to
leave but with the help of an alliance
of churches known as the new sanctuary
movement they wound up here at the old
lime Congregational Church we're in the
church basement where the family's been
in hiding
and as Anne Frank famously said no one
who goes into hiding is on the right
side of history
so you haven't set foot outside of this
church in 52 days yes okay great this is
your whole life here yes okay be happy
and be awesome looks like he was done by
a five-year-old what's it done by a
five-year-old
so that was literally a five-year-old
they made that wasn't it okay they're
cheaters maybe good they helped us it
sounds like you're living the dream you
don't have to work what are you gonna
work oh you want to work we want to do
our work the way we used to do it on the
one hand a tireless work ethic makes
them seem like the kind of immigrants
America would want but on the other hand
Americans are lazy so how will they
assimilate we came here so we started
work for the pizza delivery and after he
said okay so why not I start work inside
and learn how to make a pizza and one
day I make up my own pizza place and
last year we open up a pizza place but
pizzas American people Italian no pizza
was Italian but it came here at worked
really hard now it's American seem like
we are here in their teen years
we are Pakistani so we are American too
dog that's food it has rights I'm here
outside Malika's ate his pizza shop to
see what this foreign invasion is done
to the community I mean I wonder what
neighbor in all American business is
like polska matsuri mia by isla del
encanta and the international hair
stylist unisex salon must have thought
when an immigrant moved to town you've
chosen to run this pizza shop on the
legion's a Darin sanctuary aren't
immigrant businesses like this taking
American jobs away
created jobs when we started there were
three of them now there's 11 American
people working in this business
owned by immigrants so you're a
taxpaying business owning law-abiding
burden on the system huh classic example
I take a couple of minute please we have
to get change out of this that is P P P
P he have a bracelet on his feet so he
have to change it every six to eight
hours the battery change yes ice is
making Malik wear an ankle monitoring
device he has to keep sharp it's like
how if you let your cell phone died you
go to jail
couldn't thought to charge that before
he sat down with me I'm just saying if
my civil liberties were being violated I
think I would prepare a little better
for guests so the ankle shackle is a
sick electronic device that they put on
immigrants you have final orders I can't
think of another example in American
history where putting immigrants and
shackles went wrong you're not being
serious this is Glenn Formica Malik
inside his immigration attorney and
probable heir to a kitchen countertop
fortune hopefully he can explain why ice
needs to track the whereabouts of
someone who won't leave his current
location I think that bracelet is really
designed to break the will of people to
contest their removal if you are called
illegal if you are in constant fear and
now you have this monitoring device you
know you're gonna give up
we're not giving people basic dignity
and humanity if I wanted to get preached
to I'd go to church
oh I'm in a church but after some
quiet reflection and a few games of
brick breakers something terrible
happened I started to seem a leak inside
of like people instead of whatever
immigrants are and that made me a person
put myself again a person in there
surprisingly person like shoes and I
began to wonder what it's like to hear
that you have to leave the country
you've called home for nearly two
decades my heart almost broke my dream
go ahead did they give you any kind of
reason no I he said I have an order I
said what about my daughter I feel right
now guilty because she's five here or I
don't know what
keep thinking to be honest is much
harder to hold these beliefs when I'm
looking people who've been affected by
them in the eye so I'm gonna look over
here now oh it's better I've found a
solution if I avoid their gaze I never
have to think about what ice is doing to
this precious family and I can pretend
like they aren't even Houston here okay
all right now you have to rub it in
[Music]